are you an American yes and you don't
want to put America First no here is a
woman there were many protests Pro uh
Hamas protests in New York City and
they're showing Nazi flags and you know
great great group of people and they're
in New York City and who knows how many
of them we just L into the country uh
here's a woman uh she's not really into
America it doesn't seem like I spoke to
a guy before this and he said America
First you weren't happy with that Li
Israel would not exist without America
so know America First for you no
are you an American yes and you don't
want to put America First no no America
First for her uh the idea that Israel
would not exist without America is also
not true when the British Empire ended
in 1948 they left the British left and
then there was just land there right
there was just land they had offered we
went through this yesterday they had
offered to divy it up hey you guys you
Arabs there were no Palestinians at the
time it was not a people that existed
you Arabs will get some there was a the
1947 un partition plan you Arabs will
get some you Jews will get some Israel
would have been much smaller than it is
today but the Jews said okay we we'll
take it we'll take it it would be nice
you know we just got Holocaust it it
would be pretty nice to have a little
something that we could call ours and
not be hunted and hounded down as we
have throughout our history the Arabs
said no launch of War lost blah blah
blah but the point is uh they didn't get
the state because of America America did
recognize the state shortly after Harry
Truman did recognize the state I think
about a day after um but the but the
they got a state by living on the land
and create taking a desert and turning
it into a parad Paradise that is that is
now unfortunately not much of a paradise
but these protesters and they're they're
telling you who they are right like
they're telling you they're telling you
we sympathize with people who murder
babies and everything else and at what
point I don't know exactly what the
point is now and I think we're going to
really have to rethink this and I and I
as a look I was put on the map in large
part as a as a free speech Advocate
right someone that was fighting for free
speech at what point if all of your
allegiances as an American are to
foreign terrorist organizations and you
excuse and celebrate the murder of
innocent people all over the world at
what point uh do we have a problem on
our hands here in
America